good afternoon ladies and gentlemen I'm
Jeffrey Sachs director of the Earth
Institute at Columbia University and
like you extremely thrilled and excited
and greatly honored that we have with us
the President Macky Sall of Senegal the
president is one of Africa's most
dynamic leaders a paradigm of democracy
and of forward vision on development
from the earth Institute we take special
pleasure that he's a geologist and an
earth scientist who began in senior
positions in government as Minister of
Mines but he has been a leader in
senegalese politics for a long time with
a distinguished career and a very very
exciting prospect of his presidency he's
been Prime Minister in the previous
decade at which point we also worked
closely together on many issues of the
Millennium Development Goals he's been
president of the National Assembly and
now winning the office last year is the
president of a very dynamic and exciting
country we're also honored to have many
senegalese leaders together in the
delegation the Minister of Foreign
Affairs and the Minister of Health if I
may say a word about the Minister of
Health because she's absolutely
remarkable Minister alwa coalsack is one
of the world's leaders in public health
she was executive secretary for many
years before becoming Minister of Health
of roll back malaria and for those of
you who are following you know that
Africa is achieving historic gains
against malaria for the first time in
history malaria is coming
very very sharply and very rapidly and
we should thank dr. Alec all-sec for
that and finally I have to say though
he's not with us today that the
Senegalese cabinet includes the best
voice of any member of a cabinet in the
whole world
Minister of Culture and Tourism Youssou
N'Dour our favorite singer and we were
with you two a couple of days ago at the
broadband Commission he's a great
representative of this country and were
so thrilled let me finally say that the
earth Institute and the Institute for
African Studies and I'm honored to be
joined by our the director of the
Institute for African Studies dr.
Mamadou Diouf are extremely proud to be
working with Senegal on many different
projects and on many different fronts
education research and programs on the
ground
we love our millennium village work in
po2 Senegal and we love the fact that
all of our work for West and Central
Africa is headquartered in Dakar which
is a most wonderful city and a most
wonderful place for the headquarters of
all of our work and Mamadou are you
going to speak now or no okay
so without further ado Mamadou will be
back in mid act to take questions and
also to say a few words but without
further ado let us all together welcome
the President Macky Sall
thank you very much professor Jeffrey
Sachs for your very kind words and I
know how you are committed about African
Development and about the Millennium
religious project you are leading thank
you again thank you for my fellow
citizens teaching and this prestigious
university I'm talking about professor
Mahmoud roof and professors Philemon
Bashir Chief Dan to serve Jan and mrs. C
their teachers and few months ago I
appointed professor Suleiman Bachchan as
a chair of the High Commission the
National High Commission in charge of
how to promote higher education in in
saga for the next next for the future
and he did a very very good job very
politically I have to salute him here
distinguished Columbia University
members and staff dear students
President Lee Bollinger ladies and
gentlemen first I want to thank you for
attending this session of the world
leaders forum it is a great pleasure to
be with you and I thank professor
president Bollinger for his kind
invitation allow me also to recognize I
already did it my fellow citizen
professor Suleiman Bashir professor
Mamayev and marie MC who are teaching at
Columbia University and students who lay
low
what she is only ah okay thank you
that's the president now I will continue
my message in French because I'm afraid
you will not understand my english which
is a francophone English unless if you
want to give me hard work the first
lesson I have learned from my trip here
is the amazing perseverance of your
University in the pursuit and effort of
excellence
since 1754 when Samuel Johnson delivered
courses to the first eight students of
King's College in lower Broadway
Columbia University has built a label
that attracts respect and admiration
I would like to pay tribute to some of
your illustrious alumni namely Alexander
Hamilton governor Morris and robert
Livingston all of them who have
contributed this is decisively to the
birth of the United States of America I
speak to you today coming from a country
with a democratic tradition were voting
although it was limited to specific
category of inhabitants started in 1848
a real during a real colonial era
Senegal is also a land of diversity
where its population comprises 95
percent Muslims and they're Christians
compared Christian compatriots and other
practicing traditional religion living
in perfect harmony we believe in a world
of peaceful coexistence in justice
equity and solidarity with universal
values of democracy freedom respect of
human rights and the diversity of
civilizations throughout the ages these
values have guaranteed men's security
and human dignity they form the basis
for peaceful coexistence within and
between human communities
ladies and gentlemen the challenge of
our time is to protect these values in a
world marked by the dialectic of
contradictions never before has humanity
accumulated so much wealth however never
yet the world has ever had as many poor
as it does now we're close to a billion
people do not have access to proper food
nor education in our healthcare and even
less to electricity on the one hand the
digital system disseminates knowledge
reduces the distances amongst next word
networks and creates amongst people an
unprecedented impression of closeness on
the other hand ignorant cultural content
contempt and extremism of all kinds
divides entire communities and fanned
the flames of distrust and antagonism
there was a mention of clash of
civilizations according to the Samuel
Huntington's formula of the end of
history and the last man which according
to Francis Fukuyama heralds the absolute
and final victory of an ideal of life
and of one side over others this
perspective
from Francis Fukuyama takes us back to
the Thomas Hobbes conflictual logic man
is thought to be a wolf to a man and the
weakest will be at the mercy of the
strongest up to the last man where does
that leave our common humanity then in
Senegal
we believe that wisdom tells us that men
is a remedy for men in wool of language
knit knit I got a bomb thus the spirit
of solidarity and fraternity constitutes
the basis for human relations the late
léopold sédar senghor the first
president of independent senegal a
world-renowned poet and intellectual
translated his this humanist vision by
the concept of civilization of the
universal
he liked to add the rendezvous between
who has and will have for them to
develop he said civilization will have
to respect each other benefit from their
differences in order to converge towards
the universal taking into account the
Latins are and open conflicts around the
world dialogue is not an option but a
necessity if we want to ban the specter
of war and violence in all its forms to
that end
we mash ladies and gentlemen admit that
all civilizations all cultures are of
equal dignity and that our common
destiny is consistent with a renewed
multilateral system that is more
representative of our times it is for
this reason in the image of New York a
cosmopolitan city with linguistic
intellectual and cultural differences it
is the reason why countries like ours
plea advocate the reform of multilateral
mechanism for political and economic
cooperation since the creation of the
United Nations Organization in 1945 its
membership as well as its agenda has
have evolved significantly from 51
member in 1945 it now has a hundred and
ninety three members and yet the
composition of the whose Security
Council the linchpin of the collective
security mechanism was modified only
once from 11 to 15 members in 1965 the
need for reform of the Council of
Security is all the more urgent and
legitimate since new powers emerge and
redesign the geostrategic map of the
world in Africa a continent that counts
more than a quarter of the UN member
states are located has only three non
permanent seats of the counts at the
council we believe that this is unfair
and it does not correspond to equity and
some international so
garetty the same applies to
international economic and financial
mechanism as I indicated this morning in
one I addressed the General Assembly we
cannot validate the voice of the future
with tools from the past there is an
urgent need to rethink their governance
and the financing of the methods if we
want to work with instruments and
methods adapted to the new mutations the
world is changing and so is Africa one
example the conditions that are applied
to African countries have been defied in
what we call the Washington Consensus
which entailed putting us in a bunch of
countries that were the least advanced
and then we were poor countries the most
in debt and the but who is not in debt
some of the richest countries are more
in debt so we could have been called the
richest country with the biggest amount
of debt but that meant that we could not
borrow on the market because we could
not go very quickly so until we don't
have the condition with public aid we
don't we are not allowed to go on the
public market so how can we finish our
development our roads our bridges our
highways the energy when public aid for
development is completely falling down
disappearing so we staying as a state
like that our first ambition is to fight
against poverty and I believe that our
ambition even goes beyond that
as its at its annual assemblies in June
the African Development Bank confirmed
the outstanding performance of the
African continent over the past years
today
4/5 of the African populations live in
countries where there is peace and
stability and an economic growth above
the world average and I will remind
those of you that don't know what is
happening in Africa now that it's easier
to do Dakar in New York in eight hours
than it is to do Dakar Djibouti that
takes ten hours and I can't even mention
that car the Cape so that tells me that
Africa is a vast continent with so many
inhabitants in 54 countries States and
it is normal that there it's acceptable
that there are still some conflicts for
the first time the average GDP per
capita in Africa exceeds a thousand
dollars and seven out of ten Africans
are now connected to the world through a
mobile phone in only in sub-saharan
Africa three-quarters of the 464
billions of public spending comes from
domestic resources from within the
country in the program for
infrastructure the bi da Africa defined
a Kohan coherent set of regional
projects in the field of infrastructure
energy information and communication
technologies and the development of
cross-border basins these projects
require the mobilization of resources
which can no longer be provided by the
already limited
official development eight this is why
there is a need to promote innovative
financing mechanism such as concessions
joint ventures and public-private
partnerships for this reason we favor
the reform of the global economic and
financial governance to relax credit
conditions and simplify the procedures
for development project financing
another example that I will give you is
about our cooperation with the United
States of America through the Millennium
Challenge corporation Senegal which was
eligible in 2004 was not able to sign
its compact only until 2009 five years
of negotiation after the mission going
back and forth Washington dakar to sign
a compact for five hundred six hundred
and forty two million dollars from 2009
till today the day we speak we have
spent thirty two million dollars out of
those six hundred and forty two million
dollars this is and this is just for
study this is to tell you to let you
know the impact of the heaviness when
when there is inefficiency and until we
change those we will not be able to
reach our goals of development this is
why
the last point that I will bring up is
the environment it is a vital question
that the environment and it creates the
condition for you men for the last few
years scientists have been sounding the
alarm our planet is in a bad condition
and we do not have anywhere else where
to go for now we can't go to Mars Mars
or Jupiter we have only this planet at
the United Nations conference we we have
renewed and we still have non viable
means resources that affect the world
one-third of the production of foods
that are for human consumption is either
lost or wasted the over exploitation of
resources the gas carbonic emission and
the maritime pollution and non-viable
agricultural practices are continuing to
belittle impoverish the biodiversity
aggravate global warming and jeopardize
jeopardize the fate of current and
future generations based on the
principle of common but differentiated
responsibilities each country should
contribute to sustainable development by
preserving the resources of humanity
this motivated the decision I took when
I when I assumed office to arrest the
over exploitation of our fishery
resources by revoking the industrial
fishing licenses in order to institute a
biological rest period for the species
monsieur le président that the students
of Columbia University a citizen of the
world will continue to live up with a
wonderful vision shaped by this earth
tradition back to the time of King's
College a vision that enlarged the mind
improves the understanding furnished the
whole man and qualified them to support
the brightest character in all the
evaluated station in life thank you very
much for your
thank you very much president Sall my
name is Mahmoud edith i'm the i'm a
professor of history and African Studies
at mrs. Middle East South Asia and
African Studies and the Department of
History I also direct the Institute of
African Studies which is the platform of
all faculties and students working on
Africa and we are very pleased to be the
co-sponsor of this event with the Earth
Institute within the context of the
world Leadership Program so good
afternoon and I would like to thank you
for coming I would also like to thank
President Sall for accommodating us in
his very busy schedule but for also
accepting to stay in the u.s. in a very
difficult context and he will be living
tonight back to back are going to walk
which is the testimony and I have to say
that for two things one still here
showed that he is confident on his new
government to address the challenges of
Senegal
and it's important to say that but also
this is a testimony that he is not only
a Democratic president
democratically elected president but he
is also committed to good governance he
is responsible for the conduct of
business in Senegal but he still can
count on people to do the job so I am
moderating this aspect of a session and
I would like what I would like to do is
just to set the rules I'm sure that you
have many questions you can ask them
either in English in French but I also
think that the president will
accommodate question in Hal Paula so you
can do that
former Senegalese but don't limit
yourself to question all Senegal
President Macky Sall is also the
coordinator of NEPA the new partnership
for Africa's development so he has both
he has a continental and original rule
so you can ask questions on those so
what we have is we have to mine on the
right and on the left if you would like
to ask question but just line up behind
and I will call on you so the floor is
open
so please make sure that your questions
are concise and clear and will be able
to accommodate thank you
my name is Rihanna Diago I'm a senior at
Columbia College majoring in sustainable
development unless it water into but the
school Monsieur Macky Sall my question
Oh fancy feh an African West sorry Polly
will a necessity deities you talked
about needing to use older older tools
in order to create the solutions for
tomorrow what do you think then of the
tools and the systems that are used
during colonization and from certain
points of view that will slow down the
influence of the Senegal why can't we do
more to evaluate the current situation
to be sure that Senegal can profit from
sefa I would like to thank Raunak
thank you very much not sure
I think you've asked a very important
question we asked ourselves the same one
especially when we were students because
in our conception our first conception
that the CFA is really colonial money
and that we ought to go beyond this fact
I have to say that it's true that this
common money coming to all of the old
French colonies of Africa as well even
if the connotation is colonial it still
allows us to have a integration tool for
our countries it's not rare to see that
the eight West Africa countries come
together thanks to a common currency and
it helps them to develop the same
economic policies the same legislation
regarding customs and taxes and these
are points of conversions which allow
our common economy to have a great deal
in common so it gives us the same goals
economically this colonial connotation
phenome finally was an ace in the hole
for integration it was a very positive
point
and it'll it's up to historians and
sociologists and philosophers perhaps to
help us to find some African concept of
money and also to find a guarantee
through our work and the stability of
our economies to finally get to having a
common money a common currency a
coalesce represents now a much greater
force with 15 countries including
Nigeria and which would like to evolve
some kind of common currency for all of
us
also Ghana is going to be part of us
and we hope to be able to connect all of
West Africa in this manner we need time
for this I think we are working very
hard so that our currency won't be only
guaranteed by the French Treasury we
don't want our currency always to be
governed by European banks that means
that we don't act with our own with our
own currency we have to learn to then
have a collective African currency which
but which allows us to function
independently these are the difficulties
however that we are encountering in
African irrigation in integration and
then problems of partnerships and
agreements between the European Union
and and Africa we need to find a more
neutral currency perhaps but for them
for the time being this is a positive
currency for our West African nations
thank you so much for coming
we're so happy to have your visit I'm in
I'm in the program development of
Professor Sachs I'm a student I would
like to know with respect to the
controversies surrounding President
Obama's visit will have any
repercussions in Senegal what are you
doing in Senegal to guarantee the force
of law to get some Glee's people on
equal rights you know I just said
something kind of important I think
about the dignity of cultures and
religions on social situations you
cannot impose on Senegal something that
doesn't suit it and this ought not to
affect the economic situation because it
just becomes dictatorship to simply do
it quite simply anyway I would refuse to
do that because I'm a free man even if I
come from a formerly colonized country
we have our vision of the world and of
freedom and our vision of development
it's by dialogue consultation that we
can find some equilibrium but social
questions have no there's no monopoly on
the responses to social problems
if you agree fine if you're not if you
don't agree you can find another social
solution between my vision and that of
Obama well we have different opinions
that doesn't prevent us from being
brothers and Friends
and it also has nothing to do with the
nature of political or economic interest
between Senegal and the United States of
course Senegal guarantees all human
rights Thank You student at college and
I'd like to ask regarding your early
return what do you think is behind the
troubles of water service and the car
and what do you plan to do to fix it
when you return thank you very much
thank you very much yes for the first
time we have a situation of a technical
breakdown in the food situation and the
clean water situation it's been about
for about five days their technicians
from both sides from all sides who are
responsible for distributing water don't
manage to do so we have problems with
welding with steel up to now there have
been weaknesses in the material and I
heard that they were just making the
same pressure tests Senegal is very
vulnerable then there another problem we
have is it's not just people who are
thirsty but the economy is thirsty we
don't have funds but we're looking for
some alternative solutions to the
problem so that we can diversify the
systems of the distribution of safe
water clean water and other systems
and we also want to build a certain
amount of water towers to be able to
distribute water as it sits it's really
a shame but we're trying we need to
define a strategy so that such an
accident is never produced again never
occurs again my name is Jennifer Mahan
and I was wondering you mentioned a lot
about the challenges to infrastructure
in the environment that that's we
dollars faced and I was wondering what's
one initiative that your government is
doing to encourage um science and
technology and engineering education
among their students to ensure that the
next generation can solve these
challenges thank you very much that's an
extremely important question because
today professor Fleming Bishop who led
the collectivizing of higher education
and noted with everybody else that we
have a problem of deficit in scientific
and technical fields a huge percentage
of students are in literary fields but
how are we going to be able to fill
necessary jobs in technology engineering
etc and we also have far too many in
literary fields literary fields are
important but we need to create at the
base vocations for students when they're
young
math physics chemistry geology biology
etc our television ought to help us with
that all television shows us our dances
from morning tonight
I'm not against dancing quite the
contrary
but if there were some films about
geography etc children might be tempted
to pursue such a vocation documentaries
on the environment or the consequences
of greenhouse gases if we raised
awareness more I think we could evolve
and allâh and have more students who
would be interested in following these
fields of study as well as more
professors in those fields motivation is
what we need the more people are exposed
to this this subject matter the more
they will perhaps be able to major in
these subject at least if we could have
5050 Senate wise but right now we've got
a huge deficit as president who came out
of that same educational system I have
already ordered that all of the
laboratories that the that universities
that that all of the laboratories be
equipped with experimental all of the
experimental needs that they have the
request has been made and within the
context of a program we have modernized
the laboratories and equip them in
sciences biology etc so that teachers
and students can be in an environment of
research to be up to the challenge of
educating young scientists all those
disciplines that can help us
furthermore I think that one of the
measures good measures we I think maybe
double majors is an important thing to
do maybe a science together with
communication it's kind of easy to
convert the literary people into another
subject there is a lot to do
certainly the conclusions that I have of
you know collectivizing our thoughts and
realizing our objectives in those
domains please questions
my name is Jacob Johnson and I am a
freshman in Columbia College thank you
very much mr. president for coming here
to Columbia University today's my
question pertains to foreign economic
age and development how did the majority
of senegalese people perceive foreign
economic aid both in the colonial period
and in the post-colonial period
particularly pertaining to the
exportation of grain and other food from
the United States to Africa and also
pertaining to debt programs and finally
what do you perceive as the most
effective forms of foreign economic aid
that provide long lasting support to
Senegal and to
okay thank you sir let's see Jacob
Johnson I thanked Jacob Johnson for a
freshman you have asked pretty
intelligent questions how do senegalese
people perceive humanitarian aid I would
say that Senegal has how to write to
humanitarian aid in periods of time when
we had droughts like 2011 2000 73 and 75
Senegal however did not experienced
famine like other countries as other
countries did in 73 there was a huge
drought and the crop was reduced to
nothing there was an invasion also of
crickets and other insects who decimated
the crops that did manage to emerge in
my life political man there have been
two droughts but to complete our budget
needs see about five billion American
dollars
Africa represents today maybe 300
billion maybe about six billion dollars
600 billion dollars so this is it this
is congruent if things are in the right
proportion
what can allow us to compensate for
deficit to the extent that we that our
own decisions for development are
respected our own way our own I have
seen a lot of alienation when we are not
respected in other words even if we need
aid that's not an opportunity to do
things that are against our own will but
public aid to development is a necessity
all countries have been helped at one
point or another during their histories
all countries even the United States
when the United States wanted to acquire
its independence countries like Morocco
Morocco was the first country that
recognized the United States of America
so these are these are psyche cyclical
stories they come back all the time I'm
not a mom a man ranked in the past I'm
not I'm not looking to avenge myself on
the what was done in the past but Africa
was a victim of three centuries of the
slavery where the greatest resources of
the continent were exported towards to
America to make to favor the cotton and
the sugarcane industries after slavery
after slavery was abolished colonization
was invented in order to civilize the
peoples of Africa this was a pretext to
pillage the resources of the continent I
think today we owe Africa some kind of
reparation at least in accepting to
contribute to our development but
development is the job we're going to
have to do for ourselves after the
Second World War through the Marshall
Plan look what the United States did and
to finance infrastructure destroyed by
the war Africa needs that kind of of
help today to create its own a first
infrastructure that's why we need to be
a company we're not really asking for
aid we're asking for partnerships invest
in us do some business
create a railroad that's what Africa is
saying to the world today and I think
that this that's what we're asking for
less help than we are asking for
partnership Thank You Dignam and you
know I wanted to know what your
initiative or what your administration's
initiative is for tackling youth
unemployment in Senegal it's been a huge
discussion as part of the Millennium
Development Goals and the post-2015
agenda all across Africa and I'm
wondering what Senegal specifically is
doing to combat that and the influx of
youth migration into Europe in the u.s.
thank you very much unfortunately my
microphone has some disturbance but I
think I understand your question who did
get the listen a girl fare pretend pedal
is objective the millionaire since is a
very popular company okay what is
Senegal doing to create jobs for young
people
Madame Orman was it we are talking in
Wolof now so thank you very much the
question the question of unemployment is
universal I this question is a priority
for Humanity and by what I mean and what
I mean by that is how can we have an
inclusive growth in the world and at the
same time sufficient employment in
countries in developing countries the
incidence of unemployment is much more
visible and serious and we think that in
our case in order to struggle
effectively against youth unemployment
we have to prepare them to confront the
work market we also have to create
conditions for the development of an
investment because the government all by
itself doesn't really have the role of
just creating jobs
our job is health law and order security
for the country taxes but it's the
economy itself that creates employment
and to create jobs you need investment
and for there to be investment it's a
vicious circle as you see you really
need favorable businesses environment
where where the rule of law is
established you need a democracy you
need
struggle against impunity for those who
do not obey the law everybody has to
feel responsible and yet owed things at
the same time you need to give a good
signal to the international community
and to investors so that they will say
okay this is a stable country this
country has democracy in this country
injustice is Justices is the rule and so
I can invest professional training is
very important so that skilled labour is
is there and can respond to the
employments these are the dynamics that
favor employment if we don't do these if
we don't take these steps fundamentally
we are not going to be able to improve
the situation for young people we need
to develop sectors that create jobs
agriculture is one of those feel fields
I'm not talking about little farmers I'm
talking about modern and mechanized
farming that asurs successful crops and
we are actually developing such farms
now with young people with modern means
in order to earn a lot more money than
them was possible with more primitive
methods our young people won't need to
take boats to go outside of the country
our young people need to have lives that
are not just guaranteeing their survival
but a good life and that's what we work
on every day
I would like
so I would like to thank you all for
your participation for your great
question and for were rich answers of
President Macky Sall before giving him
an opportunity for to offer some
conclusion I would like to say that you
have seen in front of you the new
generation of African head of states
born after independence and these head
of states are facing the challenges of
rebuilding stage shaping African
responses to the ongoing process of
globalization and most of all
reinventing a future and reimagining new
tradition for the African population and
the largest group of the African
population for youth his campaign was
run under the banner of Lara - breaking
away from past political practices in
particular as you have seen
he is resolute in his fight against
corruption
he is also committed to consolidate
democracy for popular participation and
development his election marked a period
of optimism creativity and expectation
it has given you a taste of his
engagement determination and devotion to
making Africa the free Africa I would
like to thank him on your behalf on
behalf of a world leaders forum and
Columbia University and I wish him well